Consumer Price inflation remains higher
though it's likely to have peaked across
many advanced economies including in the
UK so that's a a warning that we'll
notice from the bank that they do expect
rates to come down uh they're talking
about wholesale gas prices here but
here's the key point I think here anna
UK domestic inflationary pressures have
been firmer than expected both private
sector regular pay growth and services
PMI inflation have been notably higher
than forecast in the November monetary
policy report the labor market remains
typed by historical standards although
it started to loosen and some survey
indicators of wage growth have uh eased
so the bank making the point there
really it's these high levels of uh of
wage inflation that they're starting to
see creeping through which means that
they had very little choice to but uh to
to raise interest rates uh right now and
again I'm looking at the concluding
remarks here around the policy statement
it's all about the fact that
inflationary pressures here in the UK
have been firmer than expected and the
MPC cognized into the fact that CPI the
headline rate of inflation currently
more than five times higher than the
bank's Target rate here's the
composition then uh it was indeed Swati
dingra and silvano tenrero they prefer
to maintain interest rates back rate at
three and a half percent so really no
change in the balance between the uh the
doves and the Hawks there on the
monetary policy committee and here's the
forward-looking bit that I think the
market will be most interested in uh the
line here looking further ahead the MPC
would adjust bank rate as necessary to
return inflation to the two percent
Target sustainably in the medium term
and uh again another kicker here the
extent to which domestic inflation
repressures ease will depend on the
evolution of the economy including the
impact of the significant increases in
Bank rates so far there were
considerable uncertainties around the
Outlook the MPC will continue to monitor
closely indications of persistent
inflation repressures including the
tightness of labor market conditions and
the behavior of wage growth and services
inflation and here's the key line I
think that everyone's going to hang
their hat on today if there were to be
evidence of more persistent pressures
then further tightening in monetary
policy would be required so interest
rates blank rate at four percent right
now as I said just before we got that
decision uh the markets are pricing in
right now uh bank rate to Peak at around
4.8 percent well the monetary policy
committee there in those uh in those
minutes making very very clear that
there are likely to be further interest
rate Rises uh to come we are not at what
Market participants yet refer to as the
terminal rate there will be further
interest rate Rises to come if these
sort of levels of inflation remain
persistent now bear in mind that
inflation expectations uh of the
expectations around inflation is that it
will Peak around mid-year and then start
to come or it's it's already picked in
October last year but we expect it just
start to tail off quite rapidly come the
middle of the year as you reach
annualized effects of the of the
commodity price inflation increases that
we saw last year
hey Ian King thanks very much indeed for
that rapid response to the bank of
England's decision to raise interest
rates to four percent that's their 10th
rise consecutive rise so let's get more
reaction now joining me now is our
economics and data editor Ed Conway who
has been at a briefing at the bank of
England so Ed what more can you tell us
about the thinking behind us
yeah the signal from the bank okay
there's a few things going on here
they've raised interest rates by another
half percentage Point more or less that
was expected so they're up to four
percent let's not lose sight of the fact
that that is a massive shift compared
with where you are uh only a couple of
years ago down at 0.1 so they're up a
lot compared with a few years ago
another half percentage Point increase
but I think the significant thing here
is there's been some subtle changes in
the wording So within the minutes and
that's what they kind of release
alongside a kind of explanation of why
they're taking this decision there have
been some changes where they are
signaling effectively that we are very
close to the peak in interest rates and
it's possible according to this wording
that we might well be at the peak
although they leave kind of a bit of uh
an open situation so they could raise
them by another baby cause a percentage
point maybe a half percentage point but
the signal here is that we are getting
very close to the peak in interest rates
uh four percent could maybe go up a
little bit more but we're getting close
and I think that's part of the key
message here there's a kind of
criminology when you look at these uh
the minutes and try and work out what
the central bank is trying to hint well
in this case the hint is very much last
time around it was there will be big
increases yet to come we're going to be
forceful about inflation this time
around it's signaling that we are
getting close to the peak maybe there
might be increases in interest rates
after this if inflation uh surprises on
the upside so it's a bit higher than
they expected but that is a really
interesting shift on where they were
before so definitely the signal is that
we we are if not at the peak now getting
very close to the peak according to the
bank and then the other thing that's
worth noting is on top of the actual
kind of monetary policy decisions you've
also got the forecast on the economy so
they are doing their quarterly
opportunity to look at the state of the
economy say how it's doing and the News
there well it's hard to know whether you
say it's good or bad but it's not as bad
as it was last time around so they are
last time around they were talking about
a very big fall in national income down
to kind of 1.5 in terms of the
contraction this year they've upgraded
that so it's now about 0.5 percent
that's partly down to the facts well
largely I should say down to the fact
that energy costs aren't quite so bad
gas prices down quite a lot wholesale
gas prices energy costs mean that that
cost of living shock that we're already
going through right now won't
necessarily be quite as bad in the
coming months as they previously thought
but even so they are still talking about
a technical recession so the UK
according to the bank still forecast to
be in recession this year what's a
recession is two successive quarters
where the economy is getting slightly
smaller what's the economy by the way in
this case it's national income is how
much that's growing but here's the thing
this when you look at it on a chart is
basically the smallest recession that
we've ever had in modern history it's
not really a recession I mean you know
like I say it conforms to that arbitrary
rule about what what is a recession but
it's so so small in terms of how far
below the line it's not really a
recession as I say is that good news or
bad news it's good news it's better than
it was before but in terms of the
Outlook the UK is basically flatlining
we're flatlining in it we're flatlining
not just for this year and for next year
according to their forecast we're
flatlining in the future and by 2026
according to their forecast the size of
the total economy will still be slightly
below where it was before the pandemic
so if you can kind of take that into
account we're talking about seven years
of loss economic growth following the
pandemic so you've got that forecast
side of things you've got interest rates
which they have increased but as I say
the hints and they are subtle but they
are definitely the hints that they are
trying to drop or that we are if not at
the peak for interest rates of four
percent then we are getting close to
that Peak that's the message from the
bank
and at the IMF got a lot of headlines
this week didn't they in this country
when they predicted that the UK would be
the only major economy to to plunge into
recession this year
um so is the Bank of England really in
lockstep with the IMF are they an
agreement on on the prospects for the UK
economy would you say
it's it's a good question either because
yeah that was uh quite a controversial
forecast for the international monetary
fund not necessarily so much for what it
says about the UK but more the idea that
all of the the rest of the developed
world is kind of moving up whereas the
UK is moving down it'll be interesting
to hear what the governor has to say
about this obviously we've got a press
conference coming up and we'll talk to
the governor as well about precisely
this but when you look at those numbers
within the bank's forecast they don't
forecast every single economy around the
world but they do give a kind of
Eurozone forecast for instance that's
quite a bit weaker than the IMF is
forecasting and the bank's forecast for
the UK is a bit stronger than what the
IMs is forecasting so this would
slightly kind of I wouldn't I don't know
if I'd go as far as saying contradict
but it would slightly kind of give a
ever so slightly more subtle view of it
the UK is not in a very good place
economically right now certainly but
it's not suggesting that we are a
massive outlier but as I say we'll have
to hear from the governor about that and
indeed it'll be interesting to kind of
get a sense on you know whether we are
nearing this peak as Ian was said it's
saying earlier markets still talking
about maybe rates getting up to kind of
four and a half percent or so uh in the
next year or also before potentially
coming down
will he endorse that or will he signal
that we're going to get in close to the
people either way we are now there's
kind of light at the end of the tunnel
with interest rates we've had this
period of 10 successive increases in
interest rates up to four percent and
now the bank is signaling that maybe if
there are going to be more increases
they might well be smaller there may not
be many of them that's definitely a
shift
and we just looked at a graph there Ed
showing the rise in interest rates
starting in December 2021 when the base
rate was just 0.1 percent to today's
figure of four percent I mean give us
some context for the the level that
interest rates are at the moment because
some might say well look back 20 or so
years ago they were higher than this
give us an idea of the of the context
yeah it's a really good point Anna
because actually when you look at the
the overall rate of interest rate it's
four percent it's not very high in fact
it's it's it's you know going back to
before the financial crisis you'd look
at four percent and you say that's kind
of a normal level for interest rates
maybe a little bit below the kind of
normal level but here's what's happened
since and obviously as you say back in
the 1970s and 1980s you had double-digit
uh interest rates getting up to into the
kind of teens
but what's different this time around is
that across the country people who have
mortgages tend to have higher debts okay
and so the amount that you end up having
to pay each month in repayments is
actually kind of comparable at interest
rates being kind of four or five percent
to where it was back in the 1970s and
1980s when interest rates those nominal
interest rates the ones the bank set
were much higher so the burden of
interest uh rates and the burden for
mortgage payers is pretty high right now
in fact it's getting up to kind of those
levels where before it caused some real
pain whether it's in the late 1980s uh
or indeed in the kind of 1970s so really
significant uh shift in interest rates
and it's the fact that they've come up
from basically zero in fact less than
zero when you take into account the fact
that the bank was also printing money
electronically quantitative easing meant
that money was flying into the economy
now that's gone into reverse so money is
being pulled back at the same time as
interest rates are going up all of which
help to explain why the UK is facing
tough times at the moment not just
interest rates obviously it's high
inflation it's the cost of living crisis
it's taxes going up it's the fact that
we're really sensitive to energy costs
it's brexit on top of everything else
there's a lot going on there's a
cocktail of factors but interest rates
is making things tough for many
households so I think the facts I think
that we might now be getting closer to
that Peak and the bank is dropping hints
about that that's quite significant and
it's worth us dwelling on
well yes and at bed with us a moment
because we have just got a reaction from
the chancellor Jeremy Hunt who's put out
this statement saying inflation is a
stealth tax that's the biggest threat to
living standards in a generation so we
support the bank's action today so we
succeed in halving inflation this year
that's one of Rishi sunak's five pledges
that he set out at the beginning of the
year of course the chancellor goes on to
say we will play our part by making sure
that government decisions are in
lockstep with the bank's approach
including by resisting the urge right
now to fund additional spending or tax
cuts through borrowing which will only
add fuel to the inflation fire and
prolong the pain for everyone so Ed I
wonder what you make of the Chancellor's
response to that and also reminding us
perhaps of the circumstances in which
the chancellor took over after Liz
truss's rather short-lived time in
office
it's it's more or less in line with what
you would expect from the chancellor I
mean obviously
um after what happened last year uh the
treasury very keen to underline that
they are not uh they don't want to
undermine the bank they want to to give
the impression of kind of Harmony within
the kind of different authorities that
deal with monetary policy here
um However the fact that inflation is
coming down that's something that the
bank is mostly focused on remember it's
their job to try to keep inflation as
close as possible to two percent we're
still way above that at the moment still
around that kind of 10 level it is
expected to have Peak now and it's
coming down in the coming months but
still a long way from it the bank's
forecast as it gets down to around two
percent uh by the end of the kind of
forecast Horizon so that's in a couple
of years time but still quite a long way
for it to go so that cost of living
crisis you know we're all feeling it now
unfortunately those pressures on prices
and on wages as well are likely to be
quite high for quite some time
okay Ed for the moment uh thanks very
much indeed and you were talking about
at that news conference at half past 12
I'm sure you'll be in it and there'll be
lots of interesting uh questions and
answers there but for the moment Ed
thanks very much indeed
so let's return to our panel to discuss
the implications of the rise in the base
rate of interest uh here with me are
rism Malik a mortgage broker who is
director of R3 mortgages Michael Clark
from turn to us which is a National
Poverty charity that offers support to
people facing Financial insecurity and
Vicky price chief economic advisor at
the center for economics and business
research and former joint head of the
UK's government economic service so
welcome back to you three thanks for
hanging on while we got that interest
rate decision uh Vicky price to you
first of all no big surprise this Rise
by 0.5 percent in the base rate
no um we were saying before the
announcement this was probably what was
going to happen and this is indeed
what's happened the interesting uh you
know evidence if you like coming out of
the of whatever they have produced which
was read out by uh Ian uh originally and
then of course by Conway as well um when
you were discussing it is how you
interpret uh whether they are hawkish
for the future or whether This is the
End uh and uh they've obviously been
looking at what the economy's been doing
since as well since they have very
significantly upgraded they forecast for
growth for the economy I think that's
interesting in itself uh because it
suggests that they will be looking quite
carefully particularly at issues to do
with unemployment if the economy does
better than they had anticipated then
obviously there's still going to be some
pressure on the wages front and that of
course is something which everyone who
is looking at monetary policy or or
thinking about interest rates uh will be
watching very very carefully because if
the tightness that we're seeing at
present continues then we you may get
that International inflation yes coming
down down but domestic inflation perhaps
staying with us for for considerably
longer so so that's that's the decision
which I think they're going to have to
be making over the next few months but
for the moment I think it's a sensible
increase uh and the markets May well
decide that we're not going to see
anything very much more from here on
okay I'm going to ask um you all just to
hold fire just for a moment because we
have a little bit of breaking news but I
do want to get everyone's reaction uh to
this news about interest rates but first
we've got some reaction from the prime
minister's official spokesman to the
story we've been telling you about
British gas first broken in the Times
newspaper today who reported that debt
collectors were breaking into vulnerable
customers home to fit prepayment meters
well the prime minister's spokesperson
has just said that reports today are
deeply shocking and concerning
vulnerable families should not be
treated so poorly British gas has
rightly now suspended this practice as
the energy Minister Graham Stewart is
due to meet with British gas this
afternoon at 3 30. and the spokesperson
confirmed that that meeting was in
response to the reports today as opposed
to being pre-planned so the Prime
Minister spokesperson there confirming
that the energy Minister would be
meeting British gas this afternoon at 3
30 to discuss at this news first broken
by the Times newspaper about debt
collectors entering vulnerable customers
homes
so let's rejoin our our panel and and uh
thanks for bearing with us once again
and rism Malik what you're a mortgage
broker so what do you make of the
decision today and how are the customers
approaching you going to feel about the
fact that interest rates have gone up
for the 10th consecutive time
it's just going to create more
uncertainty we're starting to have rates
calmed down after the Fiasco of the last
quarter of last year and like I said in
the last couple of weeks we've started
seeing lenders bring down rates anything
where there's sentiment for rates to go
upwards from there onwards doesn't
necessarily help even though fixed rates
aren't based on necessarily what the
rates are today they're based on Swap
rates in the future one thing that I
would say is that where there is this
constant change it's very important to
pull out your mortgage paperwork or if
your deals coming to an end to review
what you have to make sure that you're
on the best possible deal or term for
yourself so this is a great time to have
that conversation review what you have
even if you put in a mortgage
application a month two months before
with the price competition competition
the last couple of weeks it may still be
worth reviewing that even the same
lender might have brought down the
product and the pricing so it's very
important to review your mortgage at the
moment do I think the rate where I
should have been half a percent no
because by that logic until inflation
comes down to two percent we should be
having break Rises prior to today the
bank of England itself was forecasting
inflation to somewhat half by a Q4 of
this year and drop down uh to under two
percent by the year thereafter so
although I agree with why it was saying
about the rates we might be nearing the
peak of the rate Rises and that's what
people are considering when they're
thinking of locking themselves in to
long-term mortgage products well yes and
Michael Clarke you help people who get
into financial difficulty would you
agree with that advice what would you
say to anyone who hears the news that
interest rates are going up and are
concerned about paying their mortgage
I'd agree with that and also say go and
check what benefits you might be
entitled to a lot of people do not claim
all the benefits or don't realize that
their incomes have dropped to the point
where they might actually be entitled to
something so they should do a benefits
calculation they could find out if they
could get something uh I do worry about
the 14 and a half million people already
below the poverty line uh who are being
kept there by a combination of low wages
by increasing cost of living and what
the chancellor has said does make me
worry that this might be used as further
reasons for keeping those wages
artificially depressed
and Michael Clarke I raised this point
with a Conway and that there will be
some people who will have lived through
the 70s and 80s who will say but
interest rates were much higher than
four percent doesn't feel that high
compared to those times and he made the
point that people have larger debts now
on their houses would you agree that
that's one of the main issues here
um it's an issue but I'd also say and I
I will confess I did live through those
times in the 70s and 80s uh that in the
80s people proportionately had better
benefits than they do these days
proportionately they are a lot lower
than they would have been then there's a
lot less margin of error
and Vicky price looking more broadly as
well we haven't just had this interest
rate decision today from the bank of
England they've they're also setting out
their forecasts for the economy aren't
they in their quarterly report so what
have we learn so far we'll get more
details of course when we hear that news
conference but what have you learned uh
as uh to date
what we've learned is that uh as far as
the bank of England of course is
concerned and their own focus is that
we're going to see a shallower recession
that would otherwise have been the case
I think if you looked at what they were
forecasting before we were talking about
a drop maybe of 1.5 1.4 in GDP through
2023 well now the the fall is likely to
be a lot less so it is in fact as you
were asking at Conway it's very similar
to the international monetary funds
forecast of a drop of Point
um 0.5 percent uh which is bearable I
suppose you could say but within that
people will be losing out quite
significantly real incomes are being
affected wages and are rising anything
like in line with inflation except in
some sectors like the financial sector
and Professional Services maybe bits of
manufacturing as well but overall we're
seeing are people losing out quite
significantly and this interest rate
increase of course is going to make
things worse and as was mentioned also
by Conway tax increases are affecting
everyone too so we're not out of the
woods yet it and there is a question
mark about the interest rate increases
overall which is that given the
international fall in in uh prices that
we talked about earlier uh one wonders
what those interest uh rate increases
are actually achieving except just
making life much more difficult for many
people rather than necessarily bringing
down inflation uh you know quickly that
is coming down mainly because of Falls
in in gas electricity uh oil and food
prices which will eventually come
through to the consumer here as well
rather than anything significantly to do
with the interest rate increases well
interesting and rhythmatic I can see you
you nodding your head there what would
you say the impact of all this is having
more generally on the housing market
or on the housing market itself
obviously it's going to increase the uh
the options that are available to people
and potentially make the cost of boring
more expensive again depend on which
products that you're looking at but like
I said before I think that some of the
lenders have baked part of this increase
already into their mortgage products I
think those who want to move and they
have got the intention to do so will
still be doing so we haven't really seen
the big drops that we were expecting or
forecasting in property prices I think
those might come towards the middle part
of the year but yeah I completely agree
with that last point I don't think
they're necessarily in terms of
achieving their goal I don't think it
helps but the rates are the rates at the
end of the day and those are what we
have to work with
and Michael Clarke and we touched on
this a little bit before the decision
the fact that when you get an interest
rate rise obviously anyone who's got a
mortgage will be worrying about their
payments but there will be savers who
perhaps have paid off their mortgage or
or rent who will be hoping that their
interest rates will go up on their
savings are you optimistic that will
happen swiftly and what kind of
difference could that make to people who
are concerned about their money
uh if you have savings then obviously it
will have a positive impact on you it
gives you something that you can look
forward to uh if you don't have savings
and in our constituency that would be a
lot of people then it won't help you
very much
okay and and the last thought uh Vicky
on on the economy and the Outlook and
where we might head head from here do
you think we're going to get many more
interest rate rises in in the months
ahead
I think there may be one more I just
think there's going to be an awful lot
uh after that because indeed inflation
has probably peaked yes we're going to
have a little bit of a of an issue in
April when uh prices for electricity for
households go up again
um and also of course we have a lot of
the withdrawal of support to businesses
as well on the energy side so there
could be a little bit of a of an uptick
then but overall I think we'll be seeing
inflation come down quite significantly
and that would be good news in terms of
interest rates Rises for the future but
the economy is not going to do anything
very much at all and in the longer term
I think there are serious worries that
we've lost so much output because of
covid and the energy crisis as well and
haven't quite made it up yet and that's
going to drag the economy down for a
while and really interesting to hear
what the bank of England themselves say
about this and their news conference
which is in about three minutes time so
we need to wrap things up but we really
appreciate your thoughts uh Vicky price
at Michael Clarke and rismaleck thank
you all very much indeed for your
reactions
uh before that news conference let's
just bring you some breaking news about
British steel and the business secretary
Grant shaft we can bring in our city
editor Mark Kleinman so Mark what can
you tell us
yes Anna Grant chaps the business
secretary has written to the chief
executive of British Steel's owner Jing
Yi group a chinese-based conglomerate to
accuse the company of making an
unhelpful move by announcing plans for
hundreds of redundancies during talks
with the government about a separate
taxpayer funding package now we've been
covering this story over recent weeks
jinye is in discussions with government
ministers about securing 300 million
pounds of taxpayer funding but that
money is partly conditional on the
company not making uh any redundancies
for the next six months and also on
guaranteeing a proportion of its
Workforce will have their jobs preserved
for the next 10 years so the timing of
this move by British Steel's Chinese
parent is uh very odd to say the least
and I understand that Mr chaps has sent
a strongly worded letter to British
Steels parent company this morning for
the first time a British Steel confirmed
that it is indeed planning to make
redundancies said in a statement that it
was reluctantly having to consider cost
cutting in light of the global recession
and increased cost there's no mention in
the British deal statement about the
number of jobs that it is planning to
cut but we understand that it is about
800 so we should get more on this in
terms of reaction from both the company
and trade unions over the next couple of
days I would expect Anna but these plans
are unfolding uh there will be
significant redundancies at British
Steel in the weeks ahead
okay Mark thanks very much indeed for
that
well just to remind you that we are
waiting for that bank of England news
conference to start it's due in about a
minute's time and as soon as everybody
gets in the room and is ready we will
cross back there live to get the
thinking behind the rise in interest
rates of midday today and also the bank
of England's outlook for the economy but
while we wait for that let's just return
to that breaking news and the Prime
Minister responding to reports about
British gas debt collectors forcing
their way into customers homes to
install prepayment meters British unak's
spokesperson says reports today are
deeply shocking and concerning
vulnerable families should not be
treated so poorly British gas has
rightly now suspended this practice as
the energy Minister Graham Stewart is
due to meet with British gas this
afternoon at 3 30. an inquiry has now
been launched by the energy Watchdog
off-chem so that was the prime
minister's spokesperson and the story
was first reported by the times which
carried out an undercover investigation
footage showed debt collectors breaking
into vulnerable people's homes to
forcibly fit prepayment meters
it's exciting a bit I love this bit
I love this bit
well this morning the chief executive of
centrica Chris O'Shea spoke to our
business presenter Ian King who asked
him when he was first made